Are you a developer
who also gets
asked to create
Google Forms regularly
or who has a coworker who does?
Wish you could use your coding
skills to automate this?
Well, you're in the right
place, as this DevByte
was made just for you.
Welcome to the Launchpad Online.
I'm your host, Wesley Chun.
If you've ever
created a form, you
know it's a great
tool for conducting
a survey at the
office or building
a quiz for your students.
Within its editor,
you can choose
from a variety of
question options
like multiple choice, text
field, or a linear scale.
But while you can create
one, five, or even
10 forms this way,
editing each one by hand
doesn't scale if you need to
create hundreds or thousands.
So there must be a better way.
That way is a developer tool
called Google Apps Script,
which lets you build JavaScript
apps hosted in the cloud that
interact with Google Apps data
and other Google services.
Check out the link
to the intro video
if you're new to Apps Script.
In a moment, we're going to
look at how Apps Script can
be used to create forms
in bulk programmatically
to save you the time of
building them manually.
The source is available from
the post at the link you see.
So if you want to code with
me, copy it to your clipboard.
The most interesting
thing about the code
is that it's the first
one we're looking
at that's not bound to a Google
Sheet or any other document.
Let's go to the
computer now and see
how to create these
standalone scripts.
There are two ways of
creating standalone scripts.
The first is by going
to your Google Drive
and then selecting
New, More, and then
Google Apps Script, if
it's in your pull-down.
If not, then click
on Connect More Apps.
Once the search
bar comes up, you
can type Google Apps
Script, select Connect,
and once it's at it,
you'll see this dialog box,
and then the connect
button turns green.
So you can close it.
Now you can do it again:
New, More, and then
Google Apps Script.
So that's one way of doing it.
Another way of doing
it is to just go up
to the address bar in
your browser and type
script.google.com.
And this just creates
a blank project
and drops you straight
into the editor.
So all we have to do
here is take the code
that you copied earlier and
just paste it directly in here.
So walking through
the source, we
can see that we're creating a
form for conference speakers
to fill out their
talk information, bio,
and preferences.
The first step is
to create the form.
And the way to do this
is with FormApp.create.
Provide the required name, which
we call Speaker Information
Form here, and
optionally setting it
as a title, which we do here.
Once you have a form,
all you need to do
is add fields the
user should fill out.
So the first field is a
single-line text item,
which you can add to the
form with Add Text Item.
Set Title will add
the name of that item,
so you can see it on
the form, and then
we're going to require our
users to enter this field.
So that's why we call
Set Required with True.
If you want to give
users multiple lines,
instead of Add Text Item, you
would use Add Paragraph Text
Item.
If you want users to choose
from one out of multiple items,
AKA radio buttons,
create a JavaScript array
with all the choices, then
call Add Multiple Choice item,
then call Set Choice
Values with your array
so that users actually get
presented with those choices.
Finally, if instead
you want check boxes
where users can select
one or more options,
you still create an
array with their choices.
But you would call
Add Checkbox Item.
And in this last
case, we are not
going to require the
users enter this,
so we leave the
Set Required off.
Or you could also call
Set Required with False,
but that's not necessary.
Once you're done, save
it, call it something
like Conference Speaker Info.
All right.
So that's done.
So let's run it.
All right.
Now that's running.
The first thing you see is the
OAuth 2 dialog, as you expect.
So the dialog just
requests permission
to access our Google Drive.
In other words, it needs to
create this form in your Google
Drive account.
And so we want to allow that.
So once you click
Allow, OAuth succeeds.
Once the execution
bar disappears,
go to your Google Drive, and
there's our speaker information
form.
Let's click on it.
And here's our form, which you
can continue editing from here.
Or you can click View
Live Form to actually see
the form that users
will get presented with.
So you've created a form
with four user input fields,
all in just 13 lines of
code, which of course we
broke out into many more lines
to make it more readable.
And then one last thing
that you need to do
is actually assign
a spreadsheet that
will take all the data for users
when they fill out the form.
And you can do that
directly from the form
by clicking on View
Responses, or you
can either choose to create
a brand-new spreadsheet
or create a new sheet in
an existing spreadsheet.
So this is how you
would do it in the UI.
But if you wanted to
do everything in code,
at the very bottom after you've
created your form and all
the fields, you would just
make another calltoform.set
destination and
point to the sheet
where the responses
should be held.
Once you do that, all
the form responses
will go into that
sheet, and you're done.
Looking for even
more of a challenge?
Well, your next
mission is to put
the data for
multiple Google Forms
in a Google Sheet, a Doc, or
even an external database,
then enhance our code
snippet to read in that data
and auto-generate those forms.
Let me know how you do
in the comments below.
The link on screen shows one
example of what you can do.
Where do you go from here?
The first link takes you
to the Apps Script docs
where you can see an easier
example of creating a Google
form programmatically.
If you took my
challenge a moment ago
and want to create an even more
advanced forms example that
uses Sheets, Docs, Calendar,
and Gmail, go to the next link.
Finally, the resources
at the bottom
will point you to more episodes
in this and other developer
series.
So we know Google Forms is a
great tool for building surveys
and quizzes, but
it's not scalable
if you have to
create lots of forms.
By letting Google Apps Script
do all the heavy lifting,
you're no longer constrained,
because you can write an app
to auto-generate them.
Hope you learned
something today,
and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel.
This is Wesley Chun
from Google, and we'll
see you the next time
on the Launchpad Online.
[MUSIC PLAYING]